to understand what people are talking
about when they talk about a marriage
penalty let's actually calculate the
taxes for a bunch of different couples
and we're gonna calculate it as a
married couple and then also figure out
what the taxes they would have had to
pay if they never gotten married and
they filed as individuals so first have
couple a they each make a hundred
thousand dollars so if you just have an
individual who makes a hundred thousand
dollars let's think about how much they
would pay in taxes and then we can
double it because they have two of them
making a hundred thousand so on the
first from zero to eight thousand nine
hundred twenty-five they're gonna pay
ten percent around that to eight hundred
ninety three dollars on the next
increment up to thirty six thousand to
fifty they're gonna pay four thousand
ninety nine so plus four thousand ninety
nine on the increment from 36 to fifty
to eighty seven thousand eight fifty
they're gonna pay twenty five percent or
twelve thousand nine hundred plus twelve
thousand nine hundred and then they're
going to pay twenty eight percent twenty
eight percent on the increment on the
increment above eighty seven thousand
eight fifty and below a hundred thousand
so one hundred thousand one two three
minus eighty seven eight fifty gets us
to twenty one thousand two hundred and
ninety four now this is just one person
making a hundred thousand but now let's
combine it let's say well what are their
would their combined taxes have been if
they just if they never got married so
times two gets us to forty two thousand
five hundred eighty eight so forty two
thousand five hundred and eighty eight
now let's calculate it if they actually
gotten married and they file jointly as
a married couple and as well and and
they actually don't want to get married
they actually no longer have the option
of filing as an individual they now
would either have to [ __ ] married filing
jointly or do married filing separately
which does not give which would also
does not give you this bracket right
over here so we're really are comparing
what happens when you are completely
single not married to when you are
married so when you're married when
you're married we're gonna take their
combined income with two hundred K the
first seventeen thousand eight fifty is
at ten percent so that's 1785 next
increment is eight
thousand one hundred ninety eight plus
eight thousand one hundred ninety-eight
plus the next increment we still haven't
gotten to the two hundred thousand yet
is eighteen thousand four hundred
seventy-five plus eighteen thousand four
hundred seventy five plus twenty eight
percent plus twenty eight percent of the
increment below two hundred thousand and
above one hundred forty six thousand
four hundred so two hundred one two
three
- 146 four hundred gets us to
forty-three thousand four hundred and
sixty six forty three thousand four
hundred and sixty six so notice by
getting married they now have to use
this schedule if they're going to file
jointly and they pay more in taxes so
this right here is what people consider
to be the marriage penalty and just to
emphasize you might say hey why don't
they just file as an individual well
this tax bracket is no longer or these
brackets are no longer available to them
if they are married if they want if they
don't want to file jointly they could do
married filing separately but you're
still going to get the same outcome
right over here so in this case for this
couple which is they're both making an
equal amount in a fairly high income you
do have a marriage penalty they are
paying almost a thousand dollars more in
taxes let's take off think about a few
other scenarios let's take a couple B
into consideration so if they if we do
them separately so let's first take the
individual let's first take the
individual who's making a hundred eighty
thousand dollars so in the first they're
gonna pay eight hundred ninety three on
that first on that first bucket then
4099 on the bucket after that that takes
us up to thirty six thousand to fifty
then twelve thousand nine hundred plus
twelve thousand nine hundred then
they're going to pay twenty eight
percent on the increment above eighty
seven thousand eight fifty so they make
one hundred and eighty thousand this is
who were talking about one hundred
eighty one two three minus eighty seven
thousand eighty seven thousand eight
fifty gets us to and I use this all the
way up because this goes all the way to
180
thousand so it was if we had if this
184,000 we would have to think about the
next bracket but it's not so then we get
our answer so this is just the person
making four make just the person making
180,000 so to that we're going to add
the taxes that the person making 20,000
has to pay so they're gonna pay 10% on
this first bracket right over here so
that's $893 $893 then they're gonna pay
15% then they're gonna pay 15% on the
increment on 15% on the increment above
eight thousand nine hundred twenty five
so they make twenty thousand so twenty
one two three minus eight thousand nine
hundred and twenty five gets us to did I
do that right yeah that looks right gets
us to their total taxes if we just
rounded forty six thousand two hundred
and forty eight forty forty let me do
that in white forty six thousand forty
six thousand two hundred and forty eight
let me make sure I wrote that down forty
six thousand two hundred forty eight if
we round down now if they file jointly
so this is the situation where they
never get married and they both can file
individual non married than if you were
to add up their taxes is forty six
thousand two hundred and forty eight now
once they get married and they filed
jointly their combined income is the
same as couple a so they're going to pay
forty three thousand four hundred and
sixty six they're gonna pay the same
thing right over here and notice now
they actually got a marriage benefit so
this will actually this right over here
was actually a marriage benefit and the
reason why it came out as a marriage
benefit is now you had a huge disparity
in incomes right over here most of the
income was coming from this individual
right over here and by getting married
now this individual could use the
married schedule which at least in the
first few brackets increases at half the
rate over here notice this first bracket
is up to zero to eight thousand nine
hundred twenty five this is zero to
seventeen thousand eight fifty so you
have the brackets moving up not as fast
and this was most of the income and so
you actually get a Matt you actually get
a benefit by getting
now I'll leave it as an exercise to you
what happens in couples see in couples
see you they both have the same income
but their income is lower than what you
saw in couple a and you notice this
bracket right over here seventeen
thousand eight fifty is exactly double
eight thousand nine hundred twenty five
seventy two thousand five hundred is
exactly double thirty six thousand two
fifty but then 146 four hundred is not
double this right over here and so this
is where you start seeing for a scenario
like couple a where you start seeing the
marriage penalty only for a couple a
notice there was a barrage benefit for a
couple B where you start seeing the
marriage penalty kick in what you'll see
for couple C because as a couple they
fall into this there that last increment
still falls into this category right
over here it's going to be neutral
whether they get married or not and I
just want to emphasize you might be
saying well wait why doesn't anyone just
you know married filing separately which
is an option you can do married filing
separately but it is not this tax
bracket these brackets right over here
married filing separately is very it has
a very similar effect as married filing
jointly so in the case of couple a you
would still have the marriage penalty